[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef the
james beard foundation called the
darling of raleigh north carolina ashley
christensen was born and raised in the
state and grew up in a food loving
family but she didn't know she'd make
cooking her career until her first
culinary job at age 21. since then she's
opened six acclaimed restaurants and
with her wife and business partner is
co-author of two cookbooks including
their latest it's always freezer season
jamie wax sat down with them to talk
about that unusual theme and a wedding
to remember
after working in the kitchens of some of
the world's finest chefs
this is where chef ashley christensen's
own vision first became fully realized
the reimagining of a beloved downtown
diner called pools in the place she
loves most raleigh north carolina
actually when i look around this space
it's amazing to me
what you did to elevate
a southern diner but also what you did
to preserve the integrity of it i think
of it less as elevating and more of
celebrating celebrating the bones of
this place and its history
and i've said it over and over again
about this set of walls just that there
are so many great ghosts here and so
many
long-standing relationships with this
place long before i ever arrived
christensen's love of long-standing
relationships is evident in her six
incredibly diverse raleigh
establishments from beasley's chicken
and honey to poolside pies the
neapolitan inspired gourmet pizza joint
with a huge wood-fired oven as its
centerpiece
and a clever swimming pool theme
throughout the idea of playing off of
the name pools next door
and calling it poolside and pools of
course is spelled p-o-o-l-e
no matter how different the menu each of
her restaurants reflects the care
comfort and community that are central
to ashley christensen's cooking values
shared by her wife and culinary partner
caitlin golan i grew up in los angeles
in a family that loved food the adults
would just spend like several hours in
the kitchen the labor of food was never
it never felt like work it was always
part of the the time together the
fellowship together my background really
begins with my parents and and their
love for food as non-professional cooks
as home cooks the dna of christensen's
cooking comes from both parents her
mother traveled as an air force brat and
her father was a truck driver who came
home from every trip excited to share
the new recipes he had experienced on
his travels dad would come home and the
way that he would share with us to make
up for time he was away was to cook
dishes
that
he experienced on the red
food has always brought ashley and kate
together not only in life but also in
business their unique new cookbook it's
always freezer season is their latest
collaboration this book was so fun to
write because there were so many stories
and relationships that we got to pay
homage to
we love the food in this book
we're not sick of it yet the idea of
this book is to treat the freezer more
like a pantry a perfect concept for a
newly prolific crop of pandemic home
cooks
i love that you call the freezer the
most underutilized appliance in the
kitchen which is is really true right
yeah i mean for
us the freezer took on much more of a
preservation aspect than a simply a
chilling device which is i think sort of
where you start right but really what it
is in our minds is this storage space
for preserving the life of food that we
have either already made or that we you
know want to make and from their freezer
come global recipes with a southern
flair that include carnitas cornbread
panzanella with watermelon a creamy
citrusy salty dog pie and mac and cheese
with a twist pimento cheese something
most southerners know well i have to say
this custard style mac and cheese with
little hit of pimento cheese in it is
absolutely unbelievable awesome so
delicious awesome my mother will be so
excited
you know when people talk about pimento
cheese i think they think of these
store-bought tubs of something that's
very sort of gelatinous and
yeah slimy
which tastes good on its own but it's
nothing like this my pimento cheese is
inspired by my great godmother who was
from chillicothe ohio and made a very
different pimento cheese than i had ever
eaten in the south
and um so this is meant to be the
pimento cheese for people who did not
know they liked pimento peas to
the two have become a true north
carolina power couple in early 2020 the
pair wed in an elaborate but deeply
personal ceremony the two of you had the
coolest wedding i've ever seen in my
life we have some really beautiful
friendships with local musicians who
have gone into the
national world and done really fun
things and sharing their energy the
wedding was not only covered by vogue
magazine but also featured carolina
music royalty like justin vernon of
bonavere and another special guest bruce
bruce hornsby
total surprise and she like almost fell
over and as soon as i saw him i don't
know if i've ever been so speechless but
there was someone there who meant even
more than all the celebrities
her father i lost my father at the
beginning of this year but he has been
such a
always a huge part of inspiring both my
confidence and and my love for food you
named your bar for your father yeah so
my dad's uh nickname is fox and we have
a bar called fox that focus on the
personal has garnered christensen
multiple james beard awards as well as a
reputation as a champion for women in
every level of the restaurant industry
it also might be why even though ashley
christensen has all the world to choose
from she chooses to bloom where she's
planted you keep six excellent places in
a sound that you love
and just keep getting better well at
some point we realized that this this
should be about
not needing more spaces or places but
making sure that each of those evolve
and not viewing change as failure
but
exciting evolution
for cbs this morning saturday jamie wax
raleigh
okay the pimento mac and cheese is
officially now
on the menu for this weekend i think
right oh my gosh i was the lone person
eating pimento cheese sandwiches in
south carolina
because that's all i could eat and i
just love that it's in mac and mac and
cheese good wow raleigh is such a great
food city too yeah her restaurants i
mean all of those spaces look amazing i
love her i love everything about it both
of them and her wedding